[Electronic Music Bob]
Match Nick: My name is Avi Match Nick.
I am one of Aviary's founding partners.
There are currently thousands of image enhancement applications.
But what we seek to achieve is always simplifying the experience
We provide the user.
We aim to create an application that encourages you regardless
Your level of technology expertise
To actually get it
So you can in less than six seconds
From learning how to use it
And make your photos look great.
One of the most amazing features of the basic Android system
In our communication with users.
Not only are we responding to the error reports we receive.
But it extends to this continuous bilateral dialogue
With users whether through experimental uses
Or through assessments and reviews.
We also know what is happening in real time.
We can also talk to members of our forum
To see what features they like
And those who do not like them
As well as identify what they like to add to the application
In a way that has not been mentioned in our minds before
And then we execute all the required in real time.
Schafer: I was working with the Android developer console
Amazing
As compared to other basic systems.
Android lets us see metrics for our apps.
We can also search through these measures
We can also respond effectively to user feedback.
Using the new tools I would say that we are
We've been able to identify problems twice as fast.
This makes it easier for us to search through reviews
And communicate with users when we need it
And get them to learn more
All this has generally contributed to the provision
A tremendous amount of time
Anywhere from five to ten hours a week.
Darling: Android in general
Usually useful for the Aviary team.
Through which we have acquired more than two-thirds of our user base.
We use search within reviews every day.
We also use it to evaluate new features.
For example we recently issued
A new feature called Discover.
What we do is search in "Discover" to see what he is saying
Users about a product
As well as whether they like the product
Or if there are some problems you are having to use
This helps us make a decision about this product.
The ratings and reviews feature has been achieved
The benefits are enormous to us.
Because we've had the ability to browse problems quickly
By device, app version, or Android version
Then fast browsing
For user opinions
And know the actual words they use
We confirm that this is all about features that are unique to the basic Android ecosystem
This helps us to develop much more quickly.
Schafer: The response to user feedback was in the developer console
Useful to us tremendously.
For example, we recently issued a release
Included a solution to a fairly large error
It had a negative impact on our users' experience.
And moved to the developer console
I responded to all the users who were facing this error
About 50% of them actually returned
To update their reviews.
Match Nick: One of the things I like about creating apps
For the Android platform is how fast
The ability to test and publish these applications.
We have a great community of experimental users on Android
From which we can test new features.
Darling: That's what helps us identify errors
Or recognize features they like or dislike
At a much faster rate.
All of this allows us to replicate the application experience
Faster than two or three times
On Android compared to other platforms
Which is a tremendous benefit to our application.
The Aviary image enhancement program is designed to be very simple
While being a great tool for improving images at the same time.
Through dialogue with our users
Via the tools provided by us both from the developer console
And Play shop we can
Frequent application experience and much rendering
Applications across the interface are easy and simple
Which is truly remarkable for us.